[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody
how's it going happy wednesday
right wednesday ben yeah so we got to do
a day check real quick
i literally had to pull up my calendar
to remind myself
it's wednesday my dudes and uh we're we
got a special treat for you we're
playing
returnal uh we have a early access to it
and we're gonna be able to
show you the first 45 minutes of the
game
ben i just realized i don't have chat
pulled up do you do you have chat i do
i see people in here just hanging out
fantastic okay well we're just gonna hop
in here so like i said
uh we're allowed to show the first 45
minutes of the game ben's got a timer
for me that will start
uh once once we're there um
you just give me the word and i'll hit
that button so we can make sure to make
sure we're good to get going yeah
so we're good here we're starting from
the very beginning of the game i have
played a little bit in advance just so i
knew what i was doing
hopefully i won't make too much of a
fool of myself but let's hop right in
all right ready ben
yeah i'm i'm i'm great ready you want me
countdown give me a countdown
uh on three okay one
two three cool and we're off
this 45 minutes right from the get-go uh
people in the chat already calling for
gameplay it's not even been a minute my
guys it's okay we can breathe
we'll get there eventually we're gonna
get there don't worry so uh
yeah we're playing eternal for those who
don't know much about the game like i
did i actually didn't know much about it
when i
first started playing it it's basically
just like a really high budget triple a
rogue like
like it is yeah i no i actually don't
want notifications for eternal i'm good
uh yep that's okay that's okay yep
subtitles on
is this like near uh revu
i don't i don't think it's like near
it's like hades what
except it is except not as horny yeah
yeah
uh i'm thinking about near too
a lot excited yeah
oh uh
cut scene go i guess yeah sorry maybe
people just want to see the the cutscene
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
that's it that's the game pretty short
but
you know that's that's that's all the
backstory we need
uh i like how this game gets right into
it and i actually really appreciate
about it
yeah i was going to say uh it said
forbidden approach like 17 times
then she flew right into a storm and
didn't expect anything
bad to happen uh also
uh whatever that storm was made her eyes
heterochromatic and that's pretty neat
but my sidearm is missing i'm leaving
calms already
oh no i don't know if you noticed that
but
it's part of something i picked up on
part of the mystery man
yeah what's what's going on why do eyes
change color
abandoning helios heading towards white
shadow broadcast
oh yeah so this game is very much like
kind of mystery seated throughout you
don't really know why she's here she's
talking about
this thing called the white shadow
broadcast uh you'll find a lot of audio
logs that are alluding to things that
you don't
you're not really supposed to know
what's going on yet um this forest
contains extensive ruins of a xenotype
civilization
foundations and statues so like in that
regards
it it kind of has a similar thing that
um
kinda like hades does where it it does
it at least so far for me
um i'm only three hours in obviously but
it does a good job of like seeding
the mystery in the story
um as you're playing so i feel like i'm
continually
learning something new as i'm playing uh
every run yeah i i was gonna say i
i unfortunately didn't get as into hades
as
a lot of other people but i really
appreciated how it would just layer on a
little more story every time you died
anyway
it's her oh no
but i'm e
oh that's where her gun was she found it
continuing towards the signal's origin
so she's handling this a lot better than
i think most people
i agree i mean she she seems like
a like a grizzled space uh adventurer
but
at the same time i feel like that's the
first time i would have ever seen myself
dead in front of myself
hey brandon how's it going good to see
you
is that a notification not gonna go away
all right there you go there's the map
check out my my log cool readouts
happening
readouts collectibles artifacts this
will all be explained in due time
um but yeah i mean you know uh you'll
get to see examples of it as we keep
going but
like a roguelike it's got it's got all
the hallmarks you've got
uh you know randomly generated rooms
locked doors uh you have
uh like permanent upgrades you have
temporary upgrades
uh kind of having to make those choices
between
uh you know getting this upgrade but
having like a negative benefit for it
or having things be sort of like
randomized or not really sure what
you're gonna get
i also got these nasty boys right here
yeah we've got these
spaghetti lizards uh coming out of
nowhere
uh my first reaction when seeing
spaghetti wizards is to shoot for sure
oh yeah uh
so we were talking about it earlier um
i've
i've actually i've because i do mostly
trailer processing for the site
i process so many trailers for this game
and it took me until like the fifth one
to realize that it's a roguelike
yeah i literally thought it was like a
metroid like going around shooting stuff
uh scout like adventure game in space
or like like a dead space but i'm
actually kind of more into it now that i
know it's roguelike
i agree uh it reminds me like the third
person
uh 3d elements reminds me of risk of
brain two
yeah excellent roguelike but this is
like i'd say this is even more
traditional roguelike
than that game is um but this has got
like just that
that sony money you know it's true
you can tell just by looking at it um
carl's asking is the game running at 60
fps
what's the the frame rate looking like
for you uh that's a good question
um i'm not sure of the exact frame rate
but it's definitely
shooting for around 60 i feel like um
when i was playing yesterday it was
pretty darn smooth i didn't really
experience much in the way of
hitching or anything like that uh
but i could i couldn't tell you the
exact the exact frame rate but i think
it's shooting for like 60 or around 60.
all right there you go got my dash
well that's another good question uh
how's the haptic feedback for it like
what do they what do they got that going
on with uh they got some cool stuff so
uh i can't shut off yet because i don't
have a weapon that doesn't but
um when you hold down the uh
left trigger the you will
aim and if you but if you like soft hold
it down
if you click in it'll actually switch to
the weapon's alternate fire
i don't have it yet because this is the
very beginning of the game but i'll
pretty soon get a
alternate fire gun and we'll get to kind
of show what that looks like
but that is a uh
one example i've noticed so far where
they're doing uh something interesting
with like the adapter triggers and stuff
like that
yeah that's that's a good question
because i i always wonder now like when
when a game gets like a ps5 upgrade or
like we get a ps5 game like what are
they
what are we doing with that uh that dual
sense controller what's what's going on
there
right going this way this way this way
here we go uh
nhc is asking if there's a way to put
the game volume up a little bit so we
can hear it
i feel like there's too much going on
right now but okay i can pump it up a
little bit i was worried i had it too
loud but i'll pump it up a couple
if you think i need to go more let me
know
well a lot of people have near on their
minds right now
which is a cool place to be oh just
thinking about near
yeah people like oh man the projectile
they're kind of like in the air yeah
it's got the near like classic like
again like you think like rogue likes
like uh
hades and stuff like that kind of shmup
style projectile it really does feel
like they've just translated that sort
of game
into this like 3d space which i think is
really cool because i'm like
outside of a game like uh uh
risk of rain i like struggle to think of
many 3d
roguelikes um that are like at least
this faithfully roguelike
um a lot of games have sort of adopted
roguelike elements
all right let's keep going
this games can scan
so we can go 45 minutes or up until the
second boss of the second
biome i outside of like me skipping
cutscenes and rushing as much as
possible
that that's just not possible it you
know um
the the games that would take a while to
get there yeah
look at that but i will try and make
sure that we get to some
some good stuff so everyone gets to see
i've discovered piled corpses
corpses
i have tried everything i'm always
brought back by
there is a moment between death and
rebirth
when tentacles drag me down
encounter had a oh like that a little
while ago oh shoot
there's a big spaghetti monster
uh i really like the oh okay tendril
stuff that's right i feel like that was
supposed to happen i'm pretty sure it is
because um
this game is randomly generated however
that first run
was pretty much the exact same as uh
when i played it
uh previously so i think the first run
is always the same because it's sort of
like the tutorializing run
and you're hearing that audio log about
dying
and rebirthing as you jump down
helios
astra this is celine i survived that
can you hear me i'm in my ship suit
status oh you got a first person bit
uh yeah you there's occasional moments
where you go into first person
um in the little ship here which is uh
where you can look at like
uh like run stats and stuff like that
um as well as like you'll unlock
challenge stuff they have like daily
challenges like seeds you know
uh i'm done with that
uh there's also a couple of story
moments uh later on
they've got some like kojima energy
about them
that are in first person that's them
those are the magic words that's what i
like to hear
oh brandon says good to see two game
spot streams in one day
it's true uh richie was on doing some
call of duty earlier
it's
the environment wasn't like this before
okay i kind of i kind of wasn't noticing
the like
the bullet hell like
dodgeable things at first but then i saw
that wave going yeah you see it now
right
i'm like yep that's definitely it
that big old near energy
we're gonna go this way
how how far off is this game coming out
really soon
yeah because i remember it like being
this month and then it was it got pushed
back a bit or something
i think it's like i have to double check
end of the month
oh heck yeah oh i don't have enough
i don't even know what that does yet
yeah
things still left to learn mysteries
left to to solve
security system encountered
we got laser beams
you gotta have laser beams artifact
weapon proficiency
excellent oh on the 30th uh
some people are saying yeah real soon
so artifacts are
uh oh that's weird why isn't it showing
um
artifacts usually show up here in in the
items and they're like they'll stay with
you for the run
although i don't know why that isn't
showing that's weird
uh yes people also asking when reviews
will be out i don't think we know that
uh yeah maybe
i'd assume sooner there we go the alt
fire so yeah so if if you hold halfway
if you half press it
i'll do my traditional aim full press it
oh you got the charger
this will be useful
nope uh
this is a good question from omar uh
have you
only seen like the the kind of nighttime
rainy setting or
does it like shift in the day at all
have you seen that so
uh it's got different they call it
biomes i believe
um and it's sort of like think like
again like hades and sort of like okay
you're gonna go to like the different
parts of hell and they usually look
different
so after this um which we probably
unfortunately won't get to in the stream
um i just because of the timing but
the second biome is like this uh daytime
uh
like red uh desert
um that's on like the other side of the
planet so it's got like a very different
vibe so yes
uh to answer your questions the game the
game does change settings
uh quite dramatically uh already in the
second the second biome
and i imagine there are even more biomes
i'm curious
like where this game goes uh
aesthetically actually
put me in the volcano from resident evil
5. there you go i wanna
i wanna fight stuff in a volcano oh
can't do that
can i get up there
no but i can go in here aha
oh i'm not familiar with this
you know it's just it's just dropping
stuff
let's go through this door
here we go
it can be used to recover and increase
integrity
i believe this would be like a permanent
or maybe not permanent i don't know like
a
uh suit upgrade i've not gotten this
before this is
first time it looks like a nap zone to
me
okay there you go so uh that was a
health increase oh boy
uh uh uh
they give you a chance to test it out
right away i guess so
yikes there is no maneuver here
oh my gosh angry
bat creatures okay
the only widespread life forms i've
become familiar with
the parasites are everywhere
they strengthen and also weaken ah
okay
compelled can you can you shoot the
thing that's up there at all or i'm like
no okay i was like worried to shoot it i
didn't want to like anger it
that's probably a fair call
oh and i can't get that either
oh gotta keep going then is that the
thing where you need the
like the void for it yeah yeah there's a
melee weapon that'll get you that
open and that's where like some of that
metroidvania
like kind of you know oh you unlock like
the melee weapon is a permanent upgrade
so you keep it you know every run
i like that here we go
now we're talking uh larry wants to know
how the movement feels because a lot of
people are kind of noticing it's
it's quick it's very quick i like it i
like how it feels
it feels quite good
i'm curious uh if you unlock like
further upgrades over time like maybe
like
you know a double jump or something like
that would be cool but i find it it's
quite snappy and it's quite fast and i
think it feels
pretty darn good um okay so this weapon
[Music]
and then the second is this that's new i
haven't seen that before
that's kind of sick
ramen's asking about uh other items or
abilities that can carry over through
multiple runs like you're saying like
the
the melee weapon upgrade i'm assuming
weapons do no weapons actually don't
oh really i don't know weapons you have
to find every time and investigate them
you start with
you just start with a pistol every time
and the ability is random
uh they seem to be certain permanent
like health upgrades will
uh transition every time
[Music]
um there
is a upgrade that i got on my back that
at the moment i'm trying to remember
what it does but that
that stays with me
i really like the way that looks when
you send it out yeah there's some cool
cool effects on here
uh there's a teleporters you get and and
they do like this really cool like
particle
effect when you use them yeah someone
was mentioning earlier just
how how on point the particle effects
are and i'm trying to
very much agree
[Applause]
okay consumable okay yeah so you get
these little consumables that are like a
one-time use
don't don't get into those those are bad
okay
oh here you go we'll do one of these um
so there's
you can find other versions of yourself
that died like dark souls style
and then they'll show you their death
and then if you want
you can avenge them uh
doing so means you have to fight the
thing that they fought
which can be a risky move should i try
for it
uh you know what yeah why not nothing
ventured nothing gained let's see what
i'm have to fight
let's get let's get dangerous
ah something pretty brutal uh yeah as i
say
it's shooting a lot really fast
jeez
this uh is kind of like finding
dead things and then fighting them
reminds me a lot of uh
neo too which is neat yes yes it's
actually
neo is actually the more apt comparison
than like dark souls because you're
totally right
i've just been playing a lot of neo2
recently so man i know that
yeah very well i did it i was really
worried i was gonna die
uh there was there was a video it was
like oh no i've put him into a dangerous
spot making me fight this thing
um my current one's better so i'm gonna
keep
mine um
uh hustles have a chance to drop resume
on death
uh i'm gonna keep the shield one
actually i should have used that
actually when i was fighting
um i'm bad with the consumables i always
forget i have them
i i feel like there's a lot of us out
there who aren't great with using our
consumables
here we go it's always hold on to them
so these are like
uh these fabricators and then it's like
a random these ones will randomly
generate uh something
present on that same thing i'm not gonna
take it
can i get a health no i can't it's
behind the thing
oh greetings from greece hello welcome
hello to everyone who's who's hanging
out with us it's good to have you here
uh we're hanging out playing some
returnal early
uh we are timed though and where are we
at by the way
uh we're just about to hit 20 minutes
left okay
jeez yeah we've been cruising uh
so just to give you guys a heads up
we've got about 20 more minutes that we
can show
uh legally they're putting a cap on us
they're saying you can't let them see
much more than they're allowed to see
and that's the way
they've decided to just to stop us
oh this just lightning
uh i like lightning
also i like i'm gonna keep calling them
spaghetti monsters because i'm
a child yeah but i really like how the
spaghetti monsters blow up
and the tendrils kind of just fly up
into the air
yeah good design in this game
good looking things oh
what's uh
everything's got a sheep how am i
supposed to
i've never seen this before uh george i
can't tell you why it's as fast as it is
but
uh jean-luc who's playing i was talking
earlier about how it
it feels good like it it looks kind of
fast maybe because
we're not playing it but it's yeah it
doesn't it doesn't feel unwieldy when
you're playing it it might look like a
lot when you're just watching it but
when you're playing it it feels good
i don't have an issue with the way it
feels
uh okay here we go here's a permanent
upgrade i get so this is um
i'll get this like technology a little
technology that i'm going to put on my
spine
uh it's going to let me use teleporters
this is like the third time i'm calling
this out i would not
do that with dead alien and put it on
yeah she was like seems harmless and i'm
like how do you know that
it's on a dead thing performing a
function that's the only thing it's
where it's that's a naked alien who only
has that on it
okay there we go
all the way back
these chests they have uh they're
malignant
and they can basically uh give you like
a negative effect
if you open it um or you can cleanse it
i'll open it just to show
what that does uh
oh i actually didn't get it wow that was
lucky um
see this this is the run yeah you
started up the one for the stream is the
run
except that i'm going to have to quit
the time unfortunately
it won't be the run uh
time is always the run ender you know
okay uh hello i don't know how to fight
that thing
so i don't think i have the ability uh
let's see it looks like it has a shield
okay so where am i on the map i need to
go this way
you do have an objective marker that's
always telling you where to go so that's
there nice go
that lightning real god of that gun is
everything i needed
yeah the i'm actually really really
curious about the story stuff
uh i'm still
i'm still hung up on the the thing with
her eyes
all the way from back when he started i
like the story stuff so far it's got a
good hook
there's a couple cool little weird
mystery things they
they've teased so far that i've seen
maybe maybe we'll get to see some of
those
uh this is cool it's just your shop
so you can uh take your
uh your ub lights your ublets uh
you can that's where they went uh store
them for another
uh run to pick up if you want which is
cool um
and then there's like uh you can use
this to like permanently
increase some stuff uh and then i can
also pick up some other
things let's see if any of these are
worth grabbing
let's get this one this will increase my
weapon proficiency
uh what's you got oh excuse me
uh a question about loot stuff again so
the
did you get like weapons and armor you
you do get weapons
you do get weapons but like i said you
find them in the run and you have to get
new weapons each time
that's the that's the roguelike game
that we're playing we go these little
cryptic messages
discovered currently
lacking resources to decipher this
discovered a fragment of the xenotype
language
or downloading the language off the
ancient tablets
oh these guys suck they like teleport
around
oh yeah just like that was gonna say
it's gonna end up right behind you
does that lightning do some business
it's
it's good you can't beat lightning okay
don't
no you you know i love i love doing
these streams with you
and i was really excited to like to get
on here and see you play this because i
hadn't gotten a chance to see much like
the
the game play outside of the trailers
and
now that i'm getting a chance to see
like an extended amount of it
uh i
i'm really excited to actually play it
yeah
i'm sitting here like oh god this is
gonna be thing i'm just gonna boot up on
like a like a saturday morning
to do like a couple runs of and then
lose track of time and then it's gonna
be 3 a.m
it's getting oh god where did the time
goes got that vibe for sure i'm
i'm really really digging it so far i
really didn't think
i didn't really know what i was going to
do because i really didn't know much
about it but now that i've had a chance
to actually play it i'm like oh this is
this is really cool i like this a lot i
think people who like
got really into games like like i said
hades or rogue legacy or
nuclear throne because of the mechanics
uh i think we'll
really dig this game yeah and and
like robin's saying too uh they like
that there's lore in this
and there are a lot of roguelikes that
go really deep into the lore and i
i also appreciate that i would agree
oh boy what is here a lot of stuff
okay chest
that's not a chest that's like a like a
sarcophagus
as a there's a dead man inside there
jean-luc
proficiency
nope he's i
i really do not like these guys the the
pooping
crypt defenders the the angry bats
not a fan of them
there we go
also they put that health right in an
area where you'll immediately die if you
touch it which is like oh come on
yeah you know they got you
you do something with it
oh my gosh
uh what is that how good i can last time
i wasn't able to actually pick it up
why don't we try it
looks like a shotgun as i say it looks
like it's a group shotgun
this one also had electricity on it
do i want electricity or do i want
or sorry do i want the shotgun or do i
want the
let's try the shotgun let's be bold
uh nahc has another good question uh one
that i actually meant to
mention earlier uh what is the
adrenaline level
adrenaline level no because occasionally
we'll be like a dribble level down or
whatever or reset
uh i'm not entirely i need to check that
because i don't 100
remember what it does basically i do
have this parasite that's attached
itself to my arm
yeah i was gonna say you got a bug on
you now
it doesn't appear hostile it just
latched itself onto you
and weakening my suit oh
so basically it'll do uh here you go
adrenaline
adrenaline
is raised for every three house styles
you eliminate uh up to a maximum
of something upon taking damage your
adrenal level or set each level provides
a unique effect which sucks on each
other
okay so basically it's just like you
keep getting like new um little bonuses
as you as you like kill em okay and
stack them
um but it kind of goes up and goes down
as you get hit
uh but this parasite here actually will
like
do uh a positive and a negative on me so
this parasite i'll find salvage from
hostiles more often however
uh upcoming malfunctions are harder to
fix
oh oh by the way we just hit the the ten
minutes left
left oh man all right let's keep going
see what we can get
keep moving keep finding things
hey it's the guy who killed me before
maybe
oh i totally forgot about enter the
gungeon but ramen's talking about
uh that's also a very good rug like it
comes in there i like i know the gungeon
a lot
uh some more questions about the dual
sense feel
is there anything besides just the the
like alternate fire
thing on the trigger that's how i've
noticed so far um
i haven't really noticed anything about
this is better uh
like with the rumble i haven't noticed
anything in particular
oh no no no don't pick that up
[Music]
the all fires the one big one i've i can
i've noticed so far
there we go
what do we got yeah
there's some some doom eternal going on
with the dashing and
jumping in the air a little bit i can
see a little bit
anyway please look forward to my
gameplay video on
keemspot.com where we play returnal and
we just put doom music in the background
because i feel like that's a good that's
a good mashup
i'm not going to scan that suit i'm just
going to keep going
yeah we got we got we got time's
marching down i don't know what's going
on here this seems intense
oh there's tr hold on hold on a sec
oh no i'm locked i literally just left
behind a thing that was like
disabled turrets within an area and i
was like i've never seen a turret i
won't need that
oh no i know the guy is dropping on you
i mean it looks like you're not having
too much of a problem with them yeah
this guy
oh come on
this guy's got a lot of health he's like
grenades
so there is a melee weapon that we saw
it's like a like an energy sword or
something here yes yes there is a melee
weapon you get
okay this is probably what i need to
shoot
yeah that looks good i like that
okay now i can take him down
yes you can't holy cow that lightning
again
can i keep going yes i can let's just
keep going
ah yes excellent we can at least tease
it
that can't be here that doesn't belong
here
this was some of that like kojima
weirdness i was talking about
okay i'm in my memories in that house
but not fully can't go in yet i need the
cute
some parts are missing maybe
hey daniel good to see you uh awesome
looking game we got here yeah
we're having a really good time watching
jean-luc just blast everything right now
gorilla surprise surprise for me this
game
yeah they're a little healthier no
i'm kind of really excited for when it
comes out because i
and just watching this i really want to
play it
every time they blow up every time i
love it just the the stuff flying
everywhere
gun yes this one's better
well did you get the upgrade
oh it's like
like a rocket launcher like yeah like
like a homing missiles
i love it reminds your whispering tune
with
uh high fidelity graphics yeah yeah
exactly
is a very good comparison oh he's
shooting at me
i need to play more risk of rain too
played a lot during early access and
then just kind of forgot about it we're
just gonna
bounce out of here real quick
yeah that's that cool particle effect i
was talking about look at that
oh
what are we after time we are at
currently just a little under five
minutes okay
let's see if we can get to the house
i'd like to get the house i'll hit you
with the
the one minute warning
after that oh these are cool some some
stuff
you can there's more of that later but
holograms
all right you'll see that in the full
game
you got a mission you know where you're
going
what do you got for me
yeah man is that really it
dang where the heck do i go then oh did
i miss something oh okay that room
i see it i see it you got it
i feel the pressure
did you got this you've got so many
minutes left
and you're running so fast
oh i do not know what this is something
this looks like uh
like an arena where you're gonna be
fighting some stuff
oh uh excuse me oh is that the thing
that
uh killed you earlier oh man
uh it hits very hard it does
grab his health
this point of the time is going to run
out this is awesome hey anytime i'm
actually also kind of really bummed out
that we're running out of time
i know i kind of i'm kind of really into
this
and i'm having a really good time uh
i mean hey when it comes out what was it
like the 30th
yeah we could do more maybe we'll do
some more we'll come hang out we'll do
the full thing i got him
yeah let's see
currently equipped yep that's fine
what am i at uh just about to hit two
minutes
okay let's not worry about these
we don't need those
okay download that that cool glyph
house key yes yes yes oh oh am i gonna
i won't have time i don't have time to
get back there
you got a minute and a half that's more
than enough time
this this is speed run strats we're
getting ready for sgdq
we're just we're bringing it together
you've got this
gamespot is in the chats thing do it
it's fine
i don't know what that means here we go
that effect really is good though it's
really good
uh and we just hit one minute now okay
we'll get a cool minute of the house
as i left it but impossible
bump up the volume a bit
i loved my first missions in this binder
but this is stored in the mother ships
archives
the mothership
wait this is that pt hallway you can't
fool me that's what i'm saying
it's got that kojima energy this is
literally it's just the pt hallway we
came in from the other side
10 seconds
five four three
two one can i keep going can i just get
to the window
i don't know if you can i don't know
we're in we're in the danger zone now
john luke this is can i see the window
no i can't i have to go
two more all right well that is where
we're going to call it then i think
right here
you'll have to play in the full game
just like that if you want to see the
mysteries of this
spooky house and what has to do with the
story spoiler i don't know yet because
you got to play more of the game i
haven't got that far
uh but yeah thank you for joining us for
taking this look man i really wish we
could have gone longer because this game
is actually
super cool uh i i
really quite like it yeah big same i'm
i'm surprised just how much more it
seems to be
there like we've said it the whole time
just more than uh
a game where you go and do a run through
like a randomly generated
roguelike zone yeah there's the story
bits there's
the i i'm into it i won't play it
uh dude yeah big same i'm gonna i'm
gonna keep playing more because i'm
actually really really liking it
uh and like you know it feels good like
i i love the speed of it um i like me
good roguelike so
yeah uh so you know thanks for joining
us everybody uh
we should be having more um coverage of
this game pretty soon because like ben
said it comes out
on the 30th which is next week right
that is next friday so yeah uh
definitely look forward next week to
more coverage of this game including a
full review on gamespot and we'll see
you all
next time goodbye everybody
you